are you filming why why are you filming
this man
don't stop filming
are you filming
yeah okay are you visiting snapchat
yeah do i do you want to film something
yeah come on let's do we'll do one video
i'll do one video for you and then
you're going to put it away no no it's
fine it's fine what's your name
jake yeah jacob
just tell me when you're filming
you ready jacob is a [ __ ] [ __ ]
i like it when people join in i like a
bit of a heckle a bit of fun but the
most annoying one i get is when i've set
up a joke just about through the
punchline and someone goes it's all
invariably it's the same thing so it's
where's ireland where's ellen it's not
my like bet noir it's just a bit
annoying where's ellen
who's at your house [ __ ] your dad
somehow pope corki the first
doesn't command a lot of authority
now
would somebody just put a dick in that
guy's mouth please because that's what
he wants
he's a [ __ ] in disguise he's got
his mouth open because he wants someone
to come in it now do you want to keep
making noise [ __ ] and we can
find you that way are you just a punk
coward [ __ ] [ __ ] loud
[ __ ] and you're gonna shut up
now so we don't find out where the [ __ ]
you're sitting because if you keep it up
we'll grab your ass and throw you on the
[ __ ] street where you belong with
your mother and i'm [ __ ] hurting the
[ __ ] every night anyway
so [ __ ] you and your sister and your
wife if you got a kid i hope your
[ __ ] kid dies in a car fire
how do you like that you stupid
[ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up and get the
[ __ ] out of here
i'm working on this stuff
yeah really
[ __ ] up
[Applause]
gonna go and heckle an 18 year old kid
that's following his [ __ ] dreams
good luck i should show you that you're
not a good person like jokes aside you
can't go through life like this it's not
there
it really isn't fair i can't do this
this is my [ __ ] show
shut the [ __ ]
[Applause]
you up heckle unless you're in the first
four rows because i can't see you it's
chicken [ __ ]
i'm from canada too
oh now are those canadians
why are you proud to be an american
because you've never done [ __ ] for
yourself
yes that's why anyone is proud to be
from any country not just america any
country in the [ __ ] world you take
pride the same way you take pride in
dale earnhardt win in a race
you're not a fan of dale [ __ ]
earnhardt you're a fan of someone else
will take a risk so you can sit your fat
[ __ ] ass on a couch and have some slow
drip morphine injection of adrenaline so
you
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
what
it's so sad and it's unnecessary is it
all the [ __ ] swirls around in a small
circle at the bottom you have a [ __ ] job
so you pay your fifteen dollars to
bust on my [ __ ] job
all the [ __ ] swirls around in a circle
and all the people responsible for
making us all miserable aren't here to
take you
[Applause]
i'm gonna get into my [ __ ] later on i
got travis lipsky coming up
[Applause]
why are you trying to find pretty girls
in appropriate seat and not punching
those [ __ ] suckers in the face
[Applause]
[Music]
i hope your mother has herpes in the
center of her [ __ ] and you go home
tonight you lick it you get it on your
tongue
and some other horrific [ __ ] happens
that involves cancer to all of you 11
minutes left
11 minutes i hope somebody takes a
[ __ ] beer stein and just slaps you on
the back of your zit infested [ __ ]
shoulders and your awful man tip tank
tops i hope that happens to you hope the
glass [ __ ] digs into your [ __ ]
shoulder blade
and then i see you afterwards hey how's
it going you enjoy the [ __ ] show
that's great and i grab you by the
[ __ ] hair but you don't have any
they really have to come to this people
they really have to come to it
i really hope all of you run into all
those black people that you love so much
here in camden i really hope that
happens i hope there's a line of all of
you guys getting [ __ ] carjacked and
they take out their big black dicks and
they just shove them right in your
[ __ ] mouth each and every one of you
and somehow they just keep repeatingly
coming right in your [ __ ] eyeballs
until it builds up so much that your
eyes they [ __ ] cross over
you can't see [ __ ]
and somehow there's another deck in
there for you to suck
ten minutes
a bunch of left losers
[ __ ] rocky is your hero the whole
pride of your city is built around a
[ __ ] guy who doesn't even exist
[ __ ] joe frazier is from there but
he's black so you can't [ __ ] deal
with them so you make a [ __ ] statue
for some three foot [ __ ] italian you
stupid philly cheese eating [ __ ]
jackasses i hope that cheese melts your
[ __ ] faces off
all of you collectively suck a [ __ ]
dick
with a [ __ ] boobie
nine hours into a [ __ ] show
meeting you with your [ __ ] donovan
mcnabb shirt i hope he snaps both his
[ __ ] ankles for the first goddamn
game i hope you go o and [ __ ] 16. i
said suck a dick
eight minutes left
eight [ __ ] minutes left
the flyers do they even [ __ ] exist
anymore a bunch of goddamn pansies
haven't won [ __ ] since the [ __ ]
gerald thorpe was in office
once you just have the [ __ ] ice
capades down there you [ __ ] you
probably won't even notice the
difference
that [ __ ] [ __ ] teams remember they
had that whole season where they won the
slacks you bunch of [ __ ]
else what else i attacked your mothers
it's eight minutes i'm doing it all i'm
[ __ ] standing here
okay i broke the mic stand i got a
little [ __ ] cane now i'm gonna be the
little observational comedian up here
what's that sir what do you have to say
sir never pass the [ __ ] eighth grade
what brilliant [ __ ] are you gonna
[ __ ] tell me huh
go back to the dock and go unload some
[ __ ] you [ __ ] warehouse working weed
smoking [ __ ]
disappointment for your mother seven
minutes left
seven [ __ ] minutes left
and i'm doing all
[ __ ] seven
you [ __ ] [ __ ]